[موسيقى]
مساء الخير الاعلان عن عوده العلاقات
السعوديه الايرانيه بواسطه صينيه واحده من
مفاجات الشرق الاوسط العجيبه الغريبه هذه
المفاجاه بتطرح مجموعه من الاسئله اولها
طبعا لماذا وافقت السعوديه على عوده
العلاقات مع ايران ولماذا وافقت الان ماذا
تعني هذه العوده هل تعني نهايه للازمات
بين البلدين كيف يمكن ان تنعكس هذه العوده
على ملفات المنطقه الكثيره جدا والملتهبه
بسبب توتر العلاقه بين المملكه وبين
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه ما هو موقف
الاسرائيليين ما هو موقف الامريكان لكن
قبل محاوله الاجابه على كل هذه الاسئله
اذكركم بثلاثه امور سريعه الامر الاول
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايران
والصين في بيان ثلاثي مشترك اعلنوا بشكل
مفاجئ لكثير جدا من دول العالم والمراقبين
عوده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين
خلال شهرين من الاعلان يعني من 10 مارس
وتبين ان
العوده عوده العلاقات او هذا القرار جاء
بعد مفاوضات استمرت لنحو خمسه ايام من سته
مارس الى 10 مارس في بكين وتبين ايضا ان
هذه المفاوضات
بدات او كانت وليده اقتراح للرئيس الصيني
شي حين زار المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
سبعه ديسمبر 2022
وتم بحث المبادره بشكل اعمق لاستطلاع
الموقف الايراني اثناء زياره ابراهيم
رئيسي اللي هو رئيس الايراني الى بكين
ولقائه مع الرئيس التشيى في 16 فبراير
الماضي
الامر الثاني الذي ارغب ان اذكركم به انه
السعوديه قطع العلاقات مع ايران في ثلاثه
يناير
وذلك بعد ان هاجما متظاهرون مئات
المتظاهرون الايرانيون بعثات دبلوماسيه
سعوديه يعني هجموا السفاره في طهران
والقنصليه السعوديه في مشهد
والمتظاهرون هاجموا هذه البعثات احتجاجا
على اعدام السعوديه في اليوم السابق ل47
شخصا من بينهم رجل الدين نمر النمر
وبناء عليه قررت المملكه قطع العلاقات
وتضامنت معها دول اخرى فقطعت مثلا
الامارات والكويت في نفس
الاسبوع يعني العلاقات مع الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه اذكركم ايضا بالصوره الاكبر ان
العلاقه سيئه جدا بين المملكه والجمهوريه
الاسلاميه منذ عام 1979 لكن هذه العلاقات
كانت تفطر احيانا وتتحسن احيانا لكنها
تدهورت جدا في السنوات الاخيره لم تتحسن
ابدا خصوصا منذ عام 2015
لاسباب متعدده منها رفض المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الاتفاق النووي الايراني بين
الاتفاق النووي الايراني بين ايران وبين
المجتمع الدولي
ومحاولتها تخريب هذا الاتفاق ونجحت مع دول
اخرى فعلا في تخريبه الامر الثاني طبعا
انه التقارب السعودي مع اسرائيل الغير
رسمي للايران اعتقدت انه يستهدفها وهي
محقه في ذلك
الصراع بالوكاله بين الدولتين في كثير من
ساحات الصراع في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
واهمها وليس يعني الوحيد يعني اهمها
الصراع في اليمن الذي تحول الى حرب
بالوكاله بامتياز حرب عسكريه بين السعوديه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه وطبعا الاتهامات
المتبادله ايران بتتهم السعوديه بانها
طالعه في محاوله تقويد استقرار البلد
واسقاط النظام والى اخره يعني وتفتيت
ايران والسعوديه بتتهم ايران بالهجوم
عليها في 2019
و2022 الى اخره
نعود الى الاسئله التي طرحناها في اول
الحلقه لماذا وافقت السعوديه على عوده
العلاقات الاجابه باختصار ان السعوديه
والدول الخليجيه ترغب في استطلاع الحل
الدبلوماسي والسياسي ليس بدايه من مارس
ولا في 2023 ولا في 2022 ده من 2019 بعد
الهجوم الذي تعرضت اليه منشات ارامكو
الهجوم الضخم الذي تعرضت اليه هذه المنشات
في سبتمبر 2019
طب كيف يمكن لهجوم ان يدفع المملكه ودول
الخليجيه اخرى للتفكير في الخيار
الدبلوماسي لانه كانت السعوديه كانت دول
الخليج تتوقعوا ردا جادا ويعني فعالا من
الجانب الامريكي لردع ايران عن مثل هذه
اللجامات لكن الرد الامريكي في ظل اداره
الرئيس الجمهوري ترامب كان فاترا جدا لم
يفعلوا اي شيء ثم تكرر هذا الرد الفعل
الفاتر الامريكي تحت قياده الرئيس
الديمقراطي
بايدن عندما هجمت الامارات في يناير 2022
بصواريخ حوثيه مدعومه بلا شك من الجانب
الايراني
وهجمت المملكه في مارس 2022 ايضا بصواريخ
بعيده المدى من الجانب الحوثي ايضا
المدعوم من
الايرانيين على الاقل هذه قناعه الدول
الخلي جيه ودول غير الخليجيه في حقيقه
الامر وبالتالي
رد الفعل الامريكي الفاتر على الهجمات
الخليجيه في على الهجمات الايرانيه من
خلال وسطائها على السعوديه والامارات
تحت ادارتين امريكيتين
اقنعوا دول الخليج او اكدوا لدول الخليج
بثلاثه حقائق مهمه جدا الحقيقه الاولى هي
فعلا رغبه امريكا الصادقه في التخفف من
التزاماتها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط امريكا
منذ ايام اداره اوباما وهي تعلن سياساتها
المشهوره او الانتقال الى اسيا اللي هي
خلاصتها واللي اتكلمنا عنها كتير جدا وهضع
لحضراتكم بعض روابط الحلقات اللي اتكلمنا
فيه عن هذه السياسه وتاثيرها على منطقه
الشرق الاوسط ومنها حلقه بعنوان لماذا
يسعى بيض للتواصل لاتفاق مع ايران باي ثمن
انه امريكا من اكثر من عشر سنوات بتقول ان
انا استهلكت في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وان
انا ارغب في
يعني
توجيه كل قدراتي بين قوسين اللي هي
المتناقصه لمواجهه الاخطار الاكبر في اسيا
اللي هي الصين وروسيا
الامر الثاني
هو فطور خاص في العلاقه بين الامريكان
والسعوديه مع تغير الادارات المختلفه لانه
المشكله مش بس في شخص الرئيس ولكن في
المؤسسات الامريكيه الاخرى وعلى راسها
التابعه عن الكونجرس والعلاقات بين
الكونجرس والسعوديه نقدر نصفها بطريقه
مهذبه ان الود مفقود وفي حلقه انا وضحت
فيها ليه الامريكان لا يحبون المملكه
العربيه السعوديه عنوانها نوايا بيض
للمملكه في 190 كلمه يمكنكم ان تعودوا
اليها حتى لا نكرر ما جاء فيها وحكايه
الود المفقود كلمه مهذبه الحقيقه احيانا
الامريكان
بيشعروا او بيتصرفوا بنفور وغير ود مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا يقدرها
بالشكل الذي يليق بها يعني الامر الثالث
هو عجز امريكا عن مواجهه التهديدات
الايرانيه يعني بقطع النظر ان هم راغبين
في الخروج من هذه المنطقه وبقطع النظر عن
ان الامريكان لا يحملون ودا
للمملكه هم عاجزين كما تبين لدول الخليج
عن مواجهه فعاله مع الايرانيين الثلاث
قناعات ديت دفعت الخليجيين الى
الوصول الى كونكولوشن او نتيجه ان عليهم
ان يواجهوا ايران بانفسهم وانه ما حكى
جلدك مثل ظفرك كان يتبقى السؤال كيف يمكن
ان نواجه الايرانيين المواجهه انواع ايضا
باستدعاء التاريخ تبين لدول الخليج للدول
العربيه انه هم جربوا كل انواع الوسائل
لمواجهه وتحيد التهديدات الايرانيه
جربوا المواجهه العسكريه المباشره من خلال
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه من 80 ل 88 هي
حرب عراقيه ايرانيه لكنها كانت مدعومه
تماما من دول الخليج ودول عربيه اخرى
جربوا الحرب بالوكاله في سوريا وفي العراق
لكن اكثر كانت في اليمن حرب عسكريه
بالوكاله بامتياز على الاراضي اليمنيه
جربوا ايضا الانضمام للغرب في فرض عقوبات
على ايران
والعقوبات على ايران لم تنقطع على كل
الاحوال من سنه 1979
وجربوا بلا شك دون ان يعلنوا محاوله اثاره
الاضطرابات في الداخل الايراني وتغذيه كل
الحركات التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى
اسقاط النظام والضغط على ايران من الداخل
كل الوسائل دي جربت لكنها لم تؤدي الى
النتيجه المطلوبه اذا ماذا يتبقى من وسائل
المواجهه المفاوضات لكن الملحوظه ان
المفاوضات ايضا جربت يعني هم بداوا يهتموا
يبحثوا خيار المفاوضات ده بدايه من اخر
2019 وبدايه 2020 جربوه بالفعل جربوه
بدايه من ابريل 2021
واستضافت بغداد ثم مسقط جولات متتابعه من
المفاوضات المباشره بين الايرانيين وبين
السعوديين وده تحدثنا عنه في حينه في حلقه
بعنوان لماذا يمد ولي العهد يده الان الى
ايران استاذنكم ان تعودوا اليها لكن هذه
المفاوضات على اهميتها لم تؤدي لنتيجه مثل
وسائل المواجهات الاخرى العسكريه والحرب
بالوكاله
والعقوبات الى اخره اذا فما الجديد
الجديد ثلاث امور مره تانيه لماذا نجحت
المفاوضات التي قادتها الصين هذه المره
فيما فيما لم تنجح جولات المفاوضات الاخرى
التي استضافتها بغداد ومسقط في 2021 و2022
في تقديري في ثلاث مستجدات المستجد الاول
انه
العلاقات بين ايران والمجتمع الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده ووصلت الى اسوا
حالاتها ماتت كل الامال في احياء الاتفاق
النووي الايراني
وتقدم البرنامج النووي الايراني بشكل
مضطرد ومقلق جدا للخارب ومن الصعب جدا ان
يرجئوا النظر في هذه الاسوا المتصاعده ما
يعني ان فرص
الحلان للغرب اي استخدام الوسائل الخشنه
للقضاء على القدرات الايرانيه النوويه
بيتصاعد
وباختصار كده زي لو حبينا نختصر ده كان
موضوع الحلقه اللي كنت ارغب ان انا اطرحها
هذا الاسبوع قبل ان يعلن السعوديين
والايرانيون
عوده العلاقات فبدانا بهذا الموضوع لكن ان
شاء الله هنتحدث عن التطورات الخطيره
بين ايران والمجتمع الدولي والخلاصتها كده
انه مواجهه ايرانيه عسكريه بين اسرائيل او
بين الغرب وايران باتت الان اقرب من اي
وقت مضى في السنوات الاخيره
الوقت ينفذ البرنامج يتطور حتى لو سعى
الغرب الى تجنب الحرب لو سعى الغرب الى
تجنب الحرب اللي هيحدث او المتوقع واللي
حادث بدايه من 2023 هو التسارع العمليات
تخريبيه وضغوط هائله على ايران قد تفلت
الامور وهي تكون نتيجه هذا الانفلات
اندلاع مواجهه عسكريه لا يتمناها الغرب
ولكن الضغوط اللي بيفرضها والهجمات اللي
بتقودها اسرائيل يمكن ان تؤدي الى هذه
المواجهه العسكريه طيب وكيف يمكن ان يكون
قرب مواجهه عسكريه مع ايران عاملا مساعدا
للتقارب بين السعوديه وايران لان السعوديه
لانه الامارات لانه الدول الخليج الاخرى
كلها لا تريد ان تكون وقودا لمدافع هذه
الحرب لا تريد ان تكون ساحه لمعارك حرب لا
لن تبداها لا تستطيع السيطره عليها اي
خليك عندهم قلق من ايران الخليج يتمنى لو
تنتهي كل هذه المخاطر افتح قوسين واقول
بصراحه دول خليجيه السعوديه لو كان الامر
بيدها تتمنى لو تصحو في اليوم التالي وتجد
ايران قد انتقلت الى امريكا الجنوبيه
وامريكا اللاتينيه وحل محلها الارجنتين
مثلا يا ريت يتحقق ذلك لكن هذا مش ممكن
تتمنى لو تمكن الامريكان او غيرهم او
الاسرائيليون من تحل كل هذه المشاكل
بتحيدها ولو بضربه عسكريه او مجموعه ضربات
لكن هذا لا يمكن ابدا ان يتم دون تكلفه
هائله جدا جدا على الدول الخليجيه ومش انا
اللي بقول اولا ده كلام منطقي سياسيين
خارجين كثير يدركون ان الخسائر سوف تكون
هائله وهذه الخسائر سوف تكون اكثر فداحه
لان الخليجين لن يكونوا هم اصحاب اليد
العليا في تحديد توقيت المعركه ولا الى
اخره وبالتالي في رغبه من ايران اولا ان
هي وهي تعتقد ان الخطر بيقترب ان هي
تحاول درء هذا الخطر بان هي تحيد الجانب
الخليجي هي عمل ده بوسائل اخرى بس ده مش
موضوع حلقه النهارده ودول الخليج السعوديه
في هذه الحاله ترغب في ان تقول لايران لست
طرفا في العدوان الذي قد يجري عليك
وبالتالي لا مبرر ابدا ان انت تستهدفيني
بصواريخك ومصيراتك الى اخره هل هذا الموقف
جديد ابدا قبل زياره بايدن في يوليو 2022
وهذه الزياره كان احد اهدافها تكوين تحالف
عربي
عسكري يستهدف ايران كانت كل الدول العربيه
اعلنت انها لن تكون جزءا من تحالف عسكري
يستهدف ايران الكلام ده كان معلن على
السنه السعوديين والاماراتيين
والكويتيين والعراقيين الى اخره وفي حلقه
انا اتكلمت فيها بالتفصيل عن هذه
التصريحات يمكنكم ان تعودوا اليها وسوف
اضع لكم رابطها الامارات ما استنتش لما
يجي قالت يوم 15 على لسان السيد انور
قرقاش لن نكون ابدا جزءا من تحالف يستهدف
اي دوله وتحديدا ايران وقالت اعلنت
نيئاتها بشكل مبكر انها سوف ترسل او تعيد
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه التي قطعتها في
يناير 2016 تضامرا مع السعوديه واعاده
العلاقات في شهر اغسطس التالي للزياره
وكذلك فعلت الكويت على العموم ده هو السبب
الاولاني السبب الثاني
ان كثير من المتابعين ربما لا يعلمون ان
هناك مفاوضات مستمره وراء الكواليس بين
السعوديه واسرائيل والولايات المتحده
لاقناع المملكه بتطبيع العلاقات مع
اسرائيل
وان هذه المفاوضات لا تسير على النحو الذي
تتمناه السعوديه دي قصه طويله عاوزه حلقه
لوحدها لكن باختصار
السعوديه عندها مجموعه من الشروط شروط
متعدده واحد اتنين تلاته للتطبيع مع
اسرائيل انا هتوقف عند شرطين اتنين وليس
كل الشروط لان دي قصه طويله
عندهم مشكله لا يستطيع الامريكان
يعني التعامل معهما الشرط السعودي الاول
للتطبيع مع اسرائيل وفقا لتسريبات من
مسؤولين امريكان واسرائيليين
نشر في تسعه مارس الجاري ومسؤولين سعوديين
ايضا الشرط الاول
من الشروط الكثيره اللي هكتفي انا بركز
على كده علشان انا عارف ان في شروط اخرى
مهمه الشرط الاول هو ان تساعد الولايات
المتحده السعوديه في بناء
برنامجها النووي في اطلاق برنامجها النووي
الشرط الثاني هو التعهدات امنيه امريكيه
بالحفاظ على امن واستقرار المملكه عسكريا
ان هي تعرضت الى اي هجوم طيب
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل غير موافقين
على الشرطين دول الشرط الاولاني اللي هو
البرنامج النووي الايراني بالنسبه
لاسرائيل خط احمر وكذلك للولايات المتحده
لان هم صحيح السعوديه بتقول لهم ان ده
برنامج نووي سلمي بس هذه الفكره او هذا
الطلب لا ينطلع على الامريكان ولا على
الاسرائيليين لان هم عارفين انه برنامج
نووي سلمي متطور يمكن ان ينحرف الى برنامج
عسكري في اي وقت
وفي الحاله دي هيكونوا هما امام ايران
جديده هم مشكله المشاكل عندهم القدرات
النوويه والعسكريه الايرانيه الان
السعوديه عاوزه برنامج نووي سلمي قد يتطور
وهي بتطور برنامج صاروخي مع الصينيين يبقى
هنبقى قدام
هنخلص من ايران هنلاقي ايران جديده في شكل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامر الثاني
رفض الولايات المتحده للطلب السعودي
بتعهدات امريكيه
او التزامات
تعهدات ملزمه بالدفاع عنها الامر ده معناه
انه يكون في اتفاقيه رسميه زي مثلا حلف
شمال الاطلسي والمناسبه الطلب ده كان ايضا
طلبا اماراتيا
او على الاقل انه التزامات من المملكه من
الولايات المتحده
بالاستثمار في الاساطيل اللي موجوده
والتسليح السعودي المتطور الى اخره وكل
وانخراط السعوديه وانخراط الولايات
المتحده مجددا في كل متاهات المنطقه
وتطورات احداثها التي تنتهي ده بيتعارض مع
استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده في التخفف من
التزاماتها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط واحتمال
تورطها في صراع وارد جدا بين المملكه وبين
ايران
يعني يجب ان نتوقف عندها في حلقه ثانيه
لان فيها كثير من التفاصيل في اطار
التطبيع والتقارب بين اسرائيل والمملكه
المتحده والولايات المتحده لا تسير كما
تتمنى السعوديه طب وكيف يدفع ذلك السعوديه
الى تقارب مع ايران ايران السعوديه ارادت
قلب الطاوله ما هو جوهر الضغوط الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه قائم على الخطر الايراني
تقاربك معنا يا سعوديه سوف يعزز قدرتك على
ردع الايران وتحيد المخاطر الايرانيه مدام
السعوديه مش قادره توصل للاتفاق المرضي مع
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل فتقلب عليهم
الطاوله وتبدا
تقريب المسافه او تقريب الفجوه بينها وبين
ايران وفي هذه الحاله سوف تضع الولايات
المتحده
واسرائيل في الزاويه وتضغط عليهم
بايران يعني انتم بتضغطوا علي بالخطر
الايراني انا هعمل حاجه هروح لاقصى مدى في
الاتجاه الاخر وسوف اضغط عليكم بتقاربي
انا مع ايران وبالتالي اضعكم في الزاويه
واستطيع ان احصل على اكبر قدر من
التنازلات منكم الحقيقه استراتيجي نجحت
استراتيجي جيده جدا
وناجحه جدا ان هي تعمل عمليه
تتقارب مع الايرانيين وجزء من تقاربها
وضغطها على ايران هي علاقتها مع الولايات
المتحده وعلاقتها غير الرسميه مع اسرائيل
وتستغل تقاربها ومفاوضاتها مع
ايران للضغط على الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل والغرب للحصول على اكبر قدر ممكن
من الامتيازات وبالمناسبه هذا يعني ان هذه
الخطوه للسعوديه هي مفيده على كل
المستويات على الورق ان نجحت المفاوضات
وان لم تنجح ان نجحت المفاوضات مع ايران
طبعا ده هيكون يعني انجاز عظيم جدا سوف
يكون اهم تطور تشهده منطقه الشرق الاوسط
في 12 سنه اهم تطور سياسي منذ ثورات ما
سمي بالربيع العربي في 2011 امور كثيره
جدا سوف تكون ايجابيه لكن بالنسبه
للسعوديه سوف تحل ام المشكلات بالنسبه لها
الناجحت واذا لم تنجح ولو ان النجاح ده
درجات نفترض ان هي تعثرت تماما طوال فتره
المفاوضات سوف تستطيع السعوديه ان تضغط
على الولايات المتحده واسرائيل للحصول على
امتيازات كبيره السبب الثالث اللي خلى
المفاوضات هذه المره مختلفه هو دخول الصين
على الخط هذه هي المره الاولى التي يدخل
فيها دوله كبرى مقبوله ومرغوبه وصاحبه
تاثير من الطرفين ايران والسعوديه ودي قصه
يمكن ان نتحدث عنها لاحقا باختصار
ثقل الصين
كنها مقبوله من الطرفين وكون الطرفين
جاهزين لهذه الوساطه انت عارف لما يكون في
خلاف بين طرفين وكل واحد يتمنى لو يجد
وسيط يقرب وجهات النظر هذا ما فعلته الصين
لحسن حظها ولحسن حظ السعوديين والايرانيين
ده بياخدنا للسؤال الثاني ما هو موقف
الاسرائيليين من اعلان السعوديه وايران
تطبيع العلاقات الاجابه ان هذه صدمه
للاسرائيليين وفي تقدير خساره صافيه
خساره صافيه كبيره جدا
يعني لانه والكلام ده مش تحليل ده كمان
تحدث بسرعه مسؤولين اسرائيليون وعبروا عن
صدمتهم علنا رئيس وزراء اسرائيل نفتلي
بليت على سبيل المثال اللي هو كان رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل
في 2022
وصف اعاده العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران
على انه تطور مهم وخطير خطير على اسرائيل
يمثل انتصار دبلوماسي لايران ضرب حاسمه
لجهود بناء تحالف اقليمي ضد ايران وطبعا
وصلوا بانه فشل ذريع لان نتنياهو المشغول
به يعني مشاكله الداخليه ومحاوله النجاه
بجلده
من محاكمات قد تذهب به الى السجن
نفس الكلام قالوا يئير لبيد اللي اعتبر
الاتفاق فشله كامل لاسرائيل
وانهيار لجدراننا الدفاعيه الاقليميه التي
كنا نبنيها ضد ايران ده امر واضح مش محتاج
تبيان وبالتالي اذا كانت السعوديه هي
وايرانهم اكبر المستفيدين من هذا الاتفاق
فاسرائيل هي اكبر الخاسرين من هذا الاتفاق
ان تم وندعو الله ان يتم ما هو موقف
الامريكان الامريكان بيتظاهروا بان هم
سعداء بانخفاض التوتر
بعض المحللين
الامريكان ومنهم ناس يعني من العقول
الوازنه بيعتبروا انه لا يخلو من مزايا
للامريكان لان التهدئه الان تاخده
بالامريكان الامريكان مش عاوزين يذهبوا
الى صراع
مع الايرانيين الان
يتفرغوا للحرب في اوكرانيا وروسيا مع وفر
الاحترام انا اختلف في ذلك واعتقد ان هذا
الاتفاق هو خساره كبيره للولايات المتحده
لان الهدوء الذي سوف يتلو كلام مردود عليه
الحرب ما كانتش هتقوم ان قامت يعني بسبب
التوتر بين السعوديه وبين ايران
والحرائق الصغيره اللي اعتاد عليها
الامريكان نتيجه هذا التوتر هي قائمه من
سنوات ويستطيع التعايش معهم التوتر قائم
بسبب تطور البرنامج النووي الايراني اللي
بتقود اسرائيل الحمله لتصفيته وبالتالي
المشكله ما كانتش بالضبط يعني في توتر
العلاقه بين السعوديه وايران ولكن برفض
اسرائيل
للبرنامج والقدرات النوويه العسكريه بصفه
خاصه وما يعني الامريكان هو اسرائيل في
المقام الاول والثاني والثالث اثنين
انه
الهدوء لا يخلو من مزايا صحيح ولكن
ليس من مزايا هذا الاتفاق انه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تنعم بهدوء
بوساطه صينيه الاتفاق ده معناه ايه معناه
انه باختصار كده ان الصينيين قادرين على
بيقولوا للعالم لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط انا
قادرين على وضع نهايه للفوضى والاضطرابات
التي تغذيها الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
معنى كده ان الايرانيين خصوم او اعداء
الامريكان يستطيعون اكتذاب حليف امريكي
مهم زي السعوديه وانه هذه المفاوضات فتحت
الطريق للصين لتكون هي القوه قوه مسيطره
تحل محل الامريكان على الاقل في بعض
الملفات لا طبعا
هذا الاتفاق
بنتائجه باستبعاد الامريكان منه يعني
خساره او او صفعه للاداره الامريكيه يتبقى
السؤال كيف يمكن ان يعاكس هذا
الاتفاق على ملفات المنطقه الكثيره اذا
نجح هذا الاتفاق زي ما قلت لحضراتكم سوف
يكونوا انفراج ضخمه جدا وزي ما بقول مره
تانيه اهم حدث سياسي بتشهده منطقه الشرق
الاوسط منذ اندلاع ثورات الربيع العربي في
التاثير يعني
هيكون له تاثير ايجابي جدا على ملفات
ملتهبه وساخنه ولا امل في حلها الا بتقارب
الدولتين زي الملف اللبناني زي الملف
السوري زي الملف اليمني لكن
الكلام
التفصيلي عن كيف يمكن ان تنعكس هذه
المفاوضات على كل هذه الملفات من المبكر
جدا الحديث عنه
لانه يجب ان اذكركم وهو اخر شيء اقوله في
هذه الحلقه ان احنا مبتهجين جدا بعوده
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه لكن هذا الابتهاج
يجب ان يكون حذرا نحن لا نتحدث عن نهايه
المشاكل بين ايران والسعوديه نحن نتحدث عن
بدايه السعي الى حل المشاكل اما الحديث عن
نهايه المشاكل فمبكر جدا الطبيعي انما
يكون الطبيعي ان ما يكونش في انقطاع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه يعني روسيا وامريكا
بينهما حرب بالوكاله لكن في علاقات
دبلوماسيه العلاقات المتازمه جدا بين
الصين وبين الولايات المتحده لكن في
علاقات دبلوماسيه المفروض تكون في علاقات
دبلوماسيه لان ديت ليست تشريفا للدولتين
ولكن هذه القنوات اتصال يجب ان تكون قائمه
لمنع تدهور العلاقات بشكل اكبر عوده
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه امر عظيم لكنه لا
يضمن بالضروره حل المشكلات لسببين اساسيين
او لثلاث اسباب اولا المشكلات كثيره جدا
بين ايران والسعوديه اثنين الثقه ودي امر
مهم جدا في العلاقات الدوليه تقريبا
منعدمه بين الدولتين ثلاثه هناك قوه اخرى
كثيره لا ترغب في تذويب
المشكلات او حل المشكلات بين الدولتين بلد
زي اسرائيل بيعيش على التوتر الايراني
السعودي دول اوروبيه الولايات المتحده لن
تكون سعيده ابدا بذلك وبالتالي هم قادرين
على وضع المتاريس او اثاره الاضطرابات
ونسف هذا الاتفاق او على الاقل تعطيله
الخلاصه يحق لنا ان نبتهج بهذا الاتفاق
لكن يجب ان يكون الاتجاه الابتهاج حذر جدا
حتى لا نكون مثل من يحتفل بمولود قبل ان
يعقد القرار اشكركم ومع هذا الملف المهم
جدا نتابعه ان شاء الله في حلقات اخرى الى
اللقاء